turn on the radio the latest hit rhymes
crack open that book of classical
Chinese poetry sitting in your closet
those lines rhyme inside and out that
old Mayan codex sitting next to it
repeats similar sounding phrases in sets
of two germanic rhymes repeated a single
starting sound but why do humans the
world over force fit words into these
odd repeating structures what's the
reason in rhyme for rhymes people like
rhymes even more than just plain saying
what they mean you like rhymes well most
of you do but you also find them
persuasive give people a claim that
rhymes and a tweaked version that
doesn't what happens they think that the
rhyme ear one is actually truer it's one
of those mental shortcuts we take like
when my ads rhyme sounds smooth my
product is easier to choose hey so
instead of rings true should we say
rhymes true it doesn't stop there spritz
native has a heavy foreign accent so
he's hard to understand but did you know
that you're also less likely to trust
what he's saying rhymes are one of those
things that how did these researchers
put it increase processing fluency they
make my words more beautiful and more
trustworthy we could literally be using
rhymes to figure out who we trust
Pleasant easier to process trusted in
groups
sounds like the essential ingredients
for history's oldest works of literature
the oral tradition which isn't just some
old storyteller standing over a campfire
reciting five thousand line epics about
mythical animals and long dead heroes
it's also the jokes the sayings or the
ear worms that are embedded in your
memory if these guys are right memory is
the key it even puts a time limit on how
effective rhymes can be once you start a
rhyme your audience's memory buffer
expects you to finish it up within three
seconds what if our brains aren't merely
timing all right
what if we are hardwired to rhyme but
how would rhymes end up in our genes
maybe as a costly display of Fitness
which is a fancy way of saying how do I
put this in polite company rhymes were a
good way of getting people in the sack
these whale lovers think we're not the
only ones vocalizing repetitive patterns
to catch a mate recording more than 600
whale songs over 32 years they found
that the songs differed hugely between
pods but that a single pod sings a
single song that changes over time
almost deliberately the usual biological
explanation for trendy changes goes like
this mr. whale Zi over there is
improvising just enough to be attractive
but not so much that he sounds like an
outsider
it's an optimal mismatch do we crave
this balance to a rhyming sweet spot is
that why love songs make a swoon and hip
hop artists brag about their lyrical
skills or do we just like songs as much
as the next whale after all there's even
an old idea that human language rhymes
and all actually came from music maybe
we're rhythmic by nature so the next
time you throw on your favorite song and
start filling those lyrics think a bit
more about what stands behind your love
of a good rhyme
[Music]
you